jo das Youtuber treffen ist vorbei und
ich habe hier ihr seht noch ihr seht
schon ein
Ohr noch erwischt um mal kurz ein Resume
zu ziehen und es
ist hallo hi ich bin geblendet von
deiner Schönheit ne ich glaube nicht es
ist die Sonne da oben aber aus kamerch
technischen Gründen haben wir uns besser
hier ins Licht gesetzt und Leiden sind
wir gewohnt für ein gutes Bild geben wir
alles
ja wie fandst du es ich fand's geil also
es war sehr kuschelig und es war total
viel los es waren alle Leute plötzlich
um mich rum aber ich habe mich tierisch
gefreut dass so viele gekommen sind also
hätte ich echt nicht gedacht und ja es
war war geil war schon geil hast du
überhaupt mitbekommen wer alles da war
an Youtubern also ich habe gesehen und
umarmt Herr Tutorial white tity Maniac
mind und fresh tge und noch jede Menge
andere Leute wo ich dann einfach gar
nicht mehr hingeguckt habe einfach nur
umarmt und Autogramme gegeben und so
also es war irgendwann habe ich nicht
mehr hingeguckt war war zu viel aber ich
fand's schon toll dass also am Ende
waren dann noch irgendwie alle weg und
ich war nur von Gesichtern umgeben war
etwas zu viel für mich auch ein bisschen
anstrengend aber deswegen nicht scheiße
nicht scheiße nee sondern was würdest du
sagen wie war's so vom Gefühl her also
zusammenfassend
das das Wort kuschelig doch doch schon
pas super eigentlich wen ich und ist es
war entschuldigung ich habe Leid noch
ein wenig unter den nachhörungen vor
allen den als das Mikro ausgefallen ist
ich da schreien
musste oder fühst du fühltest du dich
manchmal bedrängt war es zu eng ganz am
Anfang habe ich wirklich ein Schock
gehabt als ich da reingehen wollte und
nicht irgendwie auf die Bühne oder
überhaupt durch den Raum kam also es war
es ja echt irgendwie man wurde geblendet
von Kameras von Blitzlichtern und so und
ich stand da nur wow wow und plötzlich
haben alle so T-Shirts oder so addings
hingehalten was ich unterschreiben
sollte aber irgendwann bin ich ja schon
durchgegangen und irgendwann haben sie
ja auch Platz gemacht aber dann arbeitet
man sich einfach durch ja auch wenn ich
400 Autogramme geben muss dann mache ich
das einfach ja also am Anfang fand ich
es auch super heftig aber es macht ich
habe nur gesagt ich mache mache hier
jedes Foto ich gebe jedes Autogramm bis
Z biten Ende Stunden steht genau J aber
es macht auch Spaß ich meine es ist ja
auch eine Selbstbestätigung eben genau
ich stell mir vor dass da waren Leute
aus irgendwelchen anderen Ländern direkt
da die nur für diesen Tag angekommen
sind um Autogramm oder sowas zu ergat
wenn man da sagt ne keine Zeit ich muss
zur Bühne bescheuert also da nehme ich
mir dann auf die Zeit und mach das ja
stimmt das hat lange gedauert der Büne
so ich hab ich hab wir haben doch
telefonierty ich sehe dich hallo ja ich
komme da gleich her ja das war super
machen wir es wieder ja n Klo super also
ich bin auf jeden Fall dabei gut dann
übernachte ich bei dir einfach die in
Köln und muss nicht eine Stunde
herfahren genau sie ist nämlich im
Moment
hast du Quartier in Hagen genommen das
ist eine Weile weg von Köln genau aber
dafür gibt's auch ein Gästezimmer und so
und D W ich bei dir für cou pennen kann
weiß mal schon g okay super also es gibt
ein nächstes Mal und es wird noch
fantastischer wow peace out peace
out